cuatro semanas después y no hay
respuestas esa fue la conclusión de una
misión de la organización mundial de la
salud que viajó a china para investigar
los orígenes del coronavirus los
primeros casos de kobe y 19 se
identificaron en wuhan pero los expertos
aún no saben con certeza dónde y cuando
el virus saltó por primera vez de los
animales a los humanos
no vamos a encontrar evidencia para un
día en particular y un lugar en
particular y el equipo dijo que no había
signos de grupos de infección en wuhan
ni en ningún otro lugar antes de
diciembre de 2019 pero que casos
aislados podrían haberse extendido antes
de esa fecha los científicos chinos
identificaron 72 mil pacientes con
síntomas de resfriado o gripe en los
meses previos al brote que podrían haber
sido casos tempranos de coronavirus
luego redujeron ese número a 92 y
analizaron a 67 de esas personas para
detectar anticuerpos contra el
coronavirus todos resultaron negativos
pero los expertos chinos no compartieron
datos del tamaño de la muestra original
ni tampoco explicaron los criterios que
utilizaron para seleccionar el grupo
final más pequeño la ms dice que la
información que falta les da una imagen
incompleta de lo que sucedió
queremos más datos hemos pedido más
datos y tenemos la esperanza de que eso
sea parte de los estudios de la fase 2
con los que continuaremos en las
próximas semanas
y es una mezcla de frustración y
expectativas realistas el sábado de eeuu
expresó su preocupación por la
investigación e instó a beijing a
facilitar más datos